what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with plana she has on
overalls
i don't know if that makes her look like
a farmer a painter or something in
between
but i like or a hipster or a hipster
that's a little weird
uh don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
multiple products you can earn up to
eight point six percent apy in an
interest interest-bearing account you
can get a us dollar loan to get your
bitcoin collateral
you can trade on their crypto exchange
with no fees
or you can sign up for the wait list for
their bitcoin rewards credit card
go to blockfi.compomp today and sign up
i'm an investor i'm a happy user you
will be too blockfi.com
pomp what's up all right bitcoin surged
to a fresh
record high of more than 63 000
on tuesday as investors awaited the
highly anticipated stock market debut
of cryptocurrency exchange coinbase
i don't think that bitcoin's price
appreciation has anything to do with
coinbase really
no i actually think that bitcoin's price
appreciation has to do with
exactly what we've all been saying for a
year there's a supply shock in may 2020
and when the having occurred there's a
repricing of the asset bitcoin is
following the stock to flow model
almost to perfection that is because
it is a programmatic asset you
simply need to have continued demand
increase to get the exact same price
appreciation on a percentage basis
as we have seen in the past and that is
what is happening now
the beauty is that you can predict into
the future the exact supply
of the supply and demand equation and
therefore you only need to worry about
the demand
part of the equation it's amazing what
math can do so welcome to the future
where your money is a transparent
programmatic
monetary policy it is called bitcoin it
is
slowly reaching adoption
consumer prices rise more than expected
pushed by 9.1 percent jump
in gasoline so um hold on one second i
saw something here that i wanted to oh
yeah while the inflation numbers look
high
many economists as well as policy makers
at the federal reserve expect the
increase to be
temporary april likely also will show a
sharp rise
but then the numbers are supposed to
decrease as the worst money
haven't they been saying that these
numbers are supposed to decrease for
months now
no still not even worse a couple of
months ago go back and check the
receipts they were saying inflation's
not gonna happen
now that inflation is happening it's
just temporary just as temporary
everyone chill out it's temporary
chill out is just temporary people who
are actually following this stuff
it is ridiculous the amount of times the
narrative changes
the narratives never change if you've
been listening to me you know
i've been saying the same thing since
the beginning you can't
print trillions and trillions and
trillions and trillions and trillions in
trunks that was six trillion i think
trillions and trillions and trillions
that makes it 9 trillion dollars
and expect nothing to happen you cannot
do it
but they said for months and months and
months inflation is not here
inflation will not happen we are not
worried about inflation etc
now that inflation is here now they're
at least willing to acknowledge
that there is inflation again the
unofficial inflation is
way worse than this nonsense but they're
even willing to acknowledge in the
official numbers of consumer prices that
inflation is here
now there's oh it's temporary it'll go
down maybe
or maybe it won't but what i know is
that if a clock
continues to tell you the wrong time
over and over and over again
eventually you say i don't trust the
clock
and so what when the experts the
economist
all these people say there's not going
to be inflation
and the bitcoiners are yelling there's
going to be inflation inflation's
already here
inflation beware be careful and then all
of a sudden they kind of go oh
actually the inflation that is here is
only temporary well
by the way guys people get real heated
on twitter if you mention the word
inflation they're like there is no
inflation
check it out type in the word inflation
tweet it out i might tweet about
inflation later today just to
fan the flames of the idiocracy
the what what is it called idiocy
idiot behavior okay of the economist
okay about 4.8 million millennials are
turning
30 in 2021 that's me and many are
expected to enter the home buying game
if they haven't already this wave of new
buyers will have the opportunity to
build and pass on wealth
and shape the market for years to come
are millennials buying houses
maybe i'm not buying a house i'm buying
sats that's what i'm bombing
while you all are stacking property i'm
stacking something did i buy a house
no okay no but what i do think is very
interesting is
they're claiming they're claiming that
many many more millennials are going to
go buy homes a lot of this is people
leaving cities they want to go they're
going to discover
mcmansions the whole nine yards but
remember there's a shorting of houses
of houses in the united states we make
less homes than we need literally
to the tune of as many houses are there
in the city of miami
is the deficit of homes that are created
every year and therefore what happens
when you have
low supply and high demand price has to
increase
and then you flood the market with cheap
to free capital
price increases and therefore that is
why you're seeing home prices explode
across america
can i tell you my biggest pet peeve on
the internet
every single time there's an article
that says millennials are this and
millennials are doing that
guys millennials the oldest holiday
millennials turn 40 this year the
youngest
30. these are people who are having
families who are buying homes
they are not doing social media and
like taking social media jobs speak to
yourself every time i see that i'm like
you're talking about gen
z just to be clear speak for yourself
we're not on tick tock
well maybe some of them are but you
watch tick tock all the time no i don't
i
just go next all right all right
domino's pizza and neuro inc silicon
valley startup will launch a robotic
pizza delivery service in houston this
week
as they seek to satisfy increasing
online orders
during the pandemic we've seen a few of
them robots roving around miami but i
don't think that's dominoes domino's is
one of the most forward-thinking
technology companies in the world
if you don't believe me go check the
stock price they've been killing it
because they've got online ordering
they've got all sorts of uh mobile
orders
uh they've got uh tons and tons of
technology built on the web
and uh their extension into uh
the robotics is a no-brainer it makes a
ton of sense
but i do have to say something i'm going
to have to tweet this later polina may
not like it
i saw a new york city police robot dog
video today
and they were coming out of some sort of
arrest where somebody was arrested it
was a robot dog
and he's strapped he's ready to roll
he's got the bag
no the dog didn't get arrested the
person got arrested and then all of a
sudden a robot dog
came out of the building alongside the
cops like they were rolling but it
wasn't a real dog as a robot dog
and all i'm telling y'all is that
the conspiracy theorists are probably
more right than they're wrong
oh in what world do we want police
robots
rooming the streets you got to put your
hood on for this part this is anarchist
this is not no no just right there this
is not anarchist this is freedom
this is what we're talking about freedom
do we want robot
dogs roaming the streets of new york
with facial recognition technology
armed with guns it's the equivalent of a
predator drone
walking the streets of new york that's
not what we want that's not what we want
all right it's not what we want that's
not what we're gonna get
these guys don't have weapons today i'm
saying it's a slippery slope we don't
need robot dogs
if you're a cop do your job will pay you
well and you can go in just i don't know
yesterday and you were saying no but
what i was arguing the same point saying
what
saying we don't need the robot dogs with
the weapons in france and the army
oh well in france they're going nuts the
yellow vest protests i don't know what's
going on there
but i see them they're out in the
streets and they're causing all sorts of
chaos
it might be right there was a gas
situation that was going on maybe
a little bit less protest people get
let's look at what i did
for you today i put dominoes and taco
bell in the rundown so you would be
happy but do i get a thank you i do not
get a thank you
i do all the work do i get a oh good job
people oh i don't get it people know
about taco bell taco bell we try to kill
you don't forget
don't forget that's taco bell's motto
taco taco bell we try to kill you taco
bell for some of you og viewers you'll
know what i'm talking about taco bell
won't be sponsoring this podcast anytime
soon
what are you talking about crunchwrap
supreme with no sour cream
is the go-to order everyone knows that
taco bell crunchwrap supreme
no sour cream but don't forget
we try to kill you we literally we put
you six feet under or we put you for six
minutes on the toilet that's the only
way that taco bell works
six feet under or six minutes on the
toilet taco bell
that's that's what i mean okay
taco bell that was a weird comment just
just a rock clip okay
he finds refuge in the bathroom from me
he will oh yeah i'll go to the bathroom
at any point that i possibly can
just to get away from you know no make
me don't make me get a robot dog
he'd be like i would beat up the robot
dog all right
tell them how you were scared of the
roomba he would get up on the couch
because it was he thought he was chasing
the robot everywhere i went in the house
the thing chased me i was like yo
get away from me because everywhere you
go you leave a track of dirt all right
come on
probably true taco bell we try to kill
you oh my god
taco bell will open its first digital
only u.s restaurant on wednesday in new
york's times square
to buy a crunchwrap supreme or soft taco
customers what is this chrome trap
supreme customers will have to place a
digital order ahead of their visit
or use one of the 10 self-order kiosks
inside the restaurant
welcome to the game taco bell we've been
doing this for years
inside mcdonald's are there no people
no there's people but no it's digital
only yeah but still people making the
food
oh but like nobody at the cashier yeah
i'm pretty sure
all right next it's ask lunch monet
time hold on all right
so we got a question from cryptoman976
ask lm in the comments below what's the
incentive for coinbase to go public and
deal with the extra governmental nuances
involved
with being public when they're making
more than anyone else is a private
company
are they making more than anybody else
well they're making a lot of money 1.8
billion in revenue in q1 which was more
than the 1.3 billion they made in
all of 2020. so what's the deal it's
almost like i got a good memory
what's the appeal liquidity that's what
you want you want liquidity you want to
be able to have a currency right in your
stock that you can
use to incentivize employees you can get
shareholders that you can get
public price discovery like this is a
very good thing because now all of a
sudden
those employees have been working there
for years and years and years they can
get liquidity for their stock you can
get a new shareholder base in there and
then you can use that stock you can use
it for acquisitions you can use it to
recruit new talent
you can use it to capitalize the
business you can access the public
debt or equity markets like very very
good in terms of
being able to capitalize the business
and continue to grow it yes it comes
with lots more regulation
oversight etc but normally companies
like this think the trade-off is worth
it
i need to take something public to get
liquidity all right
soggy commented said we all know pomp is
not emailing moist because in his heart
he wants to email soggy soggy
i would say kick rocks but you're
already too soggy you ain't kicking
nothing
i like soggy no i'm no more do not
double back on my guy moist what does
double back mean means going around day
90
all right boys it's not day 95 it is
he's been going let's go
i will drop everything and get on the
next flight to miami for a one-on-one
game that would be an email any day i
know you're biased you don't have to
respond to this but i probably won't
invest in coinbase just yet because i
would rather just buy bitcoin
this guy is literally you if going base
continues to succeed then it will have
been in large part because of bitcoin
i appreciate all this moist but i would
smack you in basketball it would be a
crime scene we'd have to literally call
miami dade's
finest to come show up boys i don't even
know you but i know you can
it's okay he'll give it his best
he'll do his all guys
i trus paulina one time told me she was
athletic
oh my god tell them and then on one of
the first dates we ever had we walked in
the new york public library and she
pulled her hamstring
that's because walking in the library in
the library she pulled her hamstring
there were stairs did you do it i think
so and
she literally acted like she got like it
got shut she's like ah
and she grabbed her leg and tossed her
purse to me and i uh obviously hands
team all stayed
uh i grabbed the purse out of the thin
hair like i was an athlete like
i mean we're not gonna let anything drop
around me and then she was over there
holding her leg like she literally was
jackie joyner kirsch or what was that
the woman's name the olympian
uh gail sayers over here holding her leg
like oh
do you remember that one time we were
crossing the street and my knee gave out
and i just stopped
yeah and i was like whatever all right
that's it for lunch monday today plan is
weird moist i'm coming to you no worries
talk to you all soon bang bang hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of lunch money
as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments and we'll
see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends